let's speak now to dr kathy gardner who
lost her father michael at the peak of
the pandemic spring 2020 are very sorry
for your loss thousands of families
will sense will have a sense of justice
and a sense of relief tell me how you're
feeling right now dr gardner oh huge
huge relief we knew at the time that
something had gone
so badly wrong i've known all along that
what the government did was wrong and
and today it's that vindication that
that we were right and i'm
so pleased that that's that's been
proven yeah what sort of messages of
support have you had throughout
this this
case and bringing it to the high court
you were forced to do that because you
wanted the government to be held
accountable do you feel now that they
are being held to account and that this
will change the course of future
pandemics and and possibly open
the doors to thousands of compensation
claims as well
that's there's quite a lot of questions
there i've had
fantastic support from from so many
families in a similar situation to mine
and that support has been invaluable and
indeed i wouldn't be here today had it
not been for the funding that that so
many thousands of people supported i'm
so grateful for that and this is the
vindication that we were right all along
i was right to bring the case
i was so determined to try and hold the
government to account this was such a
huge failing and i was insulted every
time they've said oh we did everything
we could and it was unprecedented and
and
no you didn't do everything you could
and no it wasn't unprecedented
and one of my main aims
was well was to make sure this never
happens again that if we're ever in this
situation again that the government will
have to make sure that they take
everything they should into account to
make sure they do whatever they can to
protect the most vulnerable people in
society when you were at home
[Music]
i imagine you weren't allowed to attend
your father's funeral but
when you were there you were mourning
for your father and you heard the
government responses
time and time again that they've thrown
a shield around care homes to protect
elderly and vulnerable
residents
how did that make you feel
i was disgusted i've been disgusted by
by the constant denial that anything was
done wrong the constant claims that they
handled the pandemic so well you know
we've had a massive death toll in this
country the top the death toll in care
homes at the start was was unbelievable
i think somewhere near half the deaths
in the first few months were care home
residents the very group of people that
should have been the most
protected by that and of course grieving
during the height of the pandemic when
we were in lockdown
was very difficult i couldn't be with my
father when he died i couldn't hold his
hand all those things that you think
will be
what you would normally expect to do
when you're losing a parent
there were three of us at his funeral
myself my husband and my mother that was
all no other family and friends at all
but all the families that have gone
through this have really been
traumatized by by losses during a
pandemic
and when you have a deep belief that the
government itself has let you down
that they've taken steps they absolutely
shouldn't have taken that's made it even
more
painful
and the constant to say the constant
denial and the constant
saying we did so well just is
is insulting
we haven't had a government response
to the judgment yet
did you ever believe that the government
had acted in the interests of the
country because it was dealing with an
unprecedented health crisis was there a
part of you before
michael died that
do you believe that the government was
trying to do its best if not actually
doing it was it actually trying to do
its best if you think
i didn't have a sense of that at the
beginning i think i
you have to remember my father died on
the third of april 2020 he got ill in
march so very very early on in in the
pandemic that we were as we were aware
of it
i think i hoped the government would do
a good job we used to have a very very
good public health system in this
country
i thought at the time in the early
months of 2020
surely we won't suffer as badly as italy
was suffering in those early days if we
remember that
but
when i realized that my father
had covered or
apparently had coveted
he was never tested
um i couldn't believe it
and then when i heard about the hospital
discharge policy and i looked it up and
i read it i couldn't believe it
that there was no mention anywhere of
how care home residents should be
protected so myself and my neighbours
were all sheltering at home keeping
ourselves safe
my father was in just a larger home
exposed completely exposed
what do you want to see happen
next we haven't had a government
response this will set a future for
further
health emergencies in the
future and
this is the first time the government
has been held accountable
pre-inquiry before any inquiry what
would you like to see happen next
well
i
have asked for an apology
from matt hancock who was secretary of
state at the time
although to me an apology is you know
it's all very well but actually i think
he also should consider his position as
an mp he's still an mp
he stood up in parliament and said to
mps that he tried to put a protective
ring around care homes i knew that was a
lie when it was said first of all in
spring 2020 and it's definitely a lie
and i think he should consider that the
prime minister absolutely should go but
i don't believe he has any conscience or
moral fibre that says that he should
take any responsibility for this but as
far as i'm concerned he absolutely does
this was under his watch